Speaker 1: There is a Republican controlled
county in Arizona that is Cochise County or it
may be pronounced goat cheese. It's not completely
clear to me. And they are refusing to certify the
election. As the Associated Press is reporting,
Republican officials in a rural Arizona county
refused yesterday to certify the 2022 election.
Here we go again. It's the same stuff. One,
this is the sequel, my friends, a decision
that was quickly challenged in court by
the state's top election official. Now, I
want to make an important distinction here.
Steve Bannon and some others when it comes to
2020, continue to talk about decertification.
We have to decertify the election. There is no
such process. There's just it doesn't exist.
This here is a different situation where they are
saying let's not certify. Certification is indeed
a process. And the secretary of state, Katie
Hobbs, is the Democratic candidate who won and
will be the governor. She has asked the judge to
order county officials to canvass the election,
which she said is an obligation under the law.
So there's a couple different things going on
here. And of course, no matter what is going on,
these right wingers will come up with some reason
why they are actually correct and everything is
absolutely right that they want to do when they
want to do it. But any time there's a different
perspective, then it must be somebody who's doing
something wrong. It's fraud. It's whatever the
case is going to be. The practice that they are
getting here is to refuse to certify a federal
election. It's important to understand that these
are always trial balloons for the next thing, and
refusing to certify a state election at the county
level is a trial for a state refusing to certify
a federal election at the state level. If this
were to happen or in any way even a fraction of
it were to happen, they would use it as precedent
for the future. That's number one. Secondly, this
isn't legal. Okay. It is absolutely correct to go
to court to try to force certification. And
these are folks who have been given a duty,
a task, an election has taken place, the ballots
have been counted. Now you have to certify there
is no analogy to and saying, well, there is
a duty to decertify. Decertification isn't
a thing. These elected officials have no duty
to decertify elections. You're you're put in a
certain position. County Board of elections, you
have to certify they're not doing it. It's a legal
issue. That's why they're going to court. Now, I
know where they are going to ultimately find the
certificate. And it's going to be, of course, in
Hunter Biden's laptop or on Hillary hard drives
emails. Right now, I believe that the grounds here
that they are claiming are, of course, completely
imaginary. This is going to be certified and
then they are going to say this is proof.
That they stole it because they came in and forced
us to certify something that shouldn't have been
certified. Of course, it's simply their job to
certify. This is still potentially very dangerous
because almost no matter what ultimately
happens with this attempt not to certify,
they are going to say, well, here's the next
thing that now we have to do at the next election,
which happens to be 2024 presidential, where
Arizona, along with a handful of other states,
could determine who's the next president
of the United States. Very scary stuff.